when was the last time you heard of a
liquor store owner going up and down the
halls of a high school trying to sell
gin
if it's legal and the profits aren't
there you're not going to have the
profit motive
for people to go out and sell it or um
i ask what when's the last time you ever
heard of a vodka addict
uh breaking into houses in order to
sport a vodka habit
you can make enough money to support it
if it's legal
uh when things are illegal they tend to
cost 20 to 25 times higher so that's
20 to 25 times as many houses as you
have to break into
on the drug part of this i find this to
be really interesting one because you
know i always describe myself as a
classical liberal and people always say
well dave you sound like a libertarian
what is a classical liberal and i always
say well look
a classical liberal in in effect is what
i would say
a really sort of a realist libertarian
is meaning that
i love all the libertarian ideas but i
understand i can't win all the time
and i'm going to have to put some some
guard rails there that that's the way i
the most simplest way that i would
describe it so in my book i talk about
the drug war and
and i'm for legalizing marijuana i'm
certainly for legalizing
um psychedelics and and then we can
whittle down every little drug
but i'm not personally for legalizing
the seriously hardcore stuff and it's
not because i want to put people in jail
because of their decisions
but but the simple truth is i know that
if someone
was cooking meth next door to me i know
that there's going to be more crime
and i know that that it's going to be
riskier to be out there and you don't
want kids there
and the rest of it so are you for
legalizing absolutely everything with no
regulations or is this a place where you
you find
some some middle ground i know you would
kick it to the states regardless but
but where do you fall on this yeah i
mean yeah the states right now have
laws on drinking and i was appalled when
i moved from a state
that you know you could drink pretty
much any time you want and then i moved
to the south and i was shocked when i
found out
what you can't buy alcohol on sunday you
know what kind of
where did i end up here and in fact we
couldn't buy alcohol on sunday until
pretty recently so
um so i you know yes i even though
i don't like those laws at least there's
some
uh competition among laws unless you get
the federal government involved
and by the way i realize i'm i'm gonna
kind of leave the topic for just a
minute just to explain real quick
because a lot of people don't know that
you know we
had when i was in school in fact i was a
bartender in college
because i was in a state where the
drinking age was only 18.
and that's the way it was back then that
different states had different drinking
ages
until elizabeth dole transportation
secretary in the 90s
came along took in you know just like
government always does federal
government always says takes in the
money
and then dangles the highway funds in
front of states and says hey
do you want your uh you want your
highway money back you're gonna have to
raise the drinking age
now we can have a debate you know maybe
21 is the better drinking age whatever
but the point is it shouldn't be the
federal government deciding that it
should
be the states so when i say okay
let's have the states you know you know
we'll let the states regulate it if they
like
i mean really let them regulate it not
have the federal government
you know back door in there trying to um
hold bribes over their heads so
they can do what they want so you really
so
so you let them do it
confused what you said because you said
that you wouldn't legalize the harder
drugs but then you talked about you know
having
um somebody having a meth lab i mean i
guess is a meth lab a heart to drug or
i'm i'm confused
yeah well well meaning i wouldn't want
if if meth was totally legal
uh then i suspect that more meth labs
would be popping up and i know that i
right now if someone moved in next door
and was cooking meth
next to me well we know it's it's
illegal and someone will hopefully do
something about it assuming we still
have a police department here in los
angeles
i'm not sure but if it was legal there
would be no recourse and we know what
will happen crime will expand you'll get
shadier people around your property
value will go down
etc well i see it completely differently
because we've got
alcohol well alcohol is legal and i just
don't hear of many people making bathtub
gin
but that's part of the problem is when
you legalize something or decriminalize
it however you want to do it
is it has to truly be legal so for
instance in california they've legalized
marijuana
but they've limited the number of people
who can sell it they've got all these
licensing laws you've got to pay all
these fees
so they're still underground there's
still an underground market there's
still people
selling marijuana illegally so that
means the laws aren't right
again when's the last time you heard of
anybody selling bathtub gin that would
cause somebody to go blind
you don't because it's it's legal to the
point that
we go down and we buy it safely so if if
meth were legal
there wouldn't be people making it next
door they'd be making it down at philip
morse or whoever
uh seagram's you know whoever makes uh
the other drugs
okay so i so i'm not with you there but
i do understand the line of thinking so
that
that's just fine but what would you say
this is where the conservatives i think
see the libertarian movement as sort of
bananas because i think this is where
conservatives would say
okay i get freedom i get states rights i
get all that stuff
but you're telling me that in effect if
there was enough
demand for meth that phil morris and
unilever
should start making meth if the market
demands it and we know that a society
filled with meth
is not great so the conservatives would
take sort of we want to
conserve sort of a functioning society
where the libertarians are saying
it's more of a free-for-all do you think
that's like a fair
it's just sort of like a philosophically
different spot
well i think they're misguided first off
if you look
where marijuana is legal you haven't
seen
increase in marijuana use let's say in
teenagers and you haven't seen
it um basically abused you know i
i again we look at alcohol i'm right but
marijuana is not marijuana is not highly
addictive the way meth or
you know some opiates you know some of
the more hardcore stuff is
well alcohol is highly addictive
tobacco's highly addictive those are
very highly addictive in fact
our own surgeon general said that uh
tobacco was the
former surgeon general i believe it was
sievert coop who said that
tobacco was just as uh highly addictive
as heroin
so uh and and yet that's legal
but you know what we have right now is
we've got
drugs being illegal and so they don't go
for help
and even look at where it starts you
know again when was the last time you
heard of a liquor store owner going up
and down the halls of a high school
trying to sell gin
if it's legal and the profits aren't
there you're not going to have the
profit motive
for people to go out and sell it or um i
ask
what when's the last time you ever heard
of a vodka addict uh
breaking into houses in order to support
a vodka habit you can make enough money
to support it if it's legal
uh when things are illegal they tend to
cost 20 to 25 times higher so that's
20 to 25 times as many houses as you
have to break into
and so i'm looking at it and by the way
i'm not a drug user well actually i am
bourbon is my drug of choice
yes bourbon is a drug and i i got a
graduate certificate in drug
and alcohol studies and i understand
that
the way our neurotransmitters work
alcohol is actually a very dangerous
drug much more dangerous than marijuana
um but somehow somehow i got through the
1970s in high school and college never
having tried marijuana i gotta admit you
know i'm a goody two shoes
but the the point here is there's not
a profit motive you know well when
people ask me about
legalizing uh drugs the point is
and they say well but i don't use drugs
so i don't care i say but you should
care if you care about crime
you should care if your kids are in a
school because right now there's a
profit motive
to get your kids hooked on drugs and and
high school kids themselves will say you
know it's a lot easier to buy marijuana
than it is to buy alcohol yeah because
alcohol is legal there's not the profit
in there there's competition it's we've
got the free market out there taking
care of it
so how about let's have the free market
take care of the other things and then
if you do have a heroin problem let's
treat it
as a medical issue and not a a
you know a criminal issue if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell